[Music]
Collins
gift bags and Applause
This Plane full of Chinese tourists was
greeted in Thailand by cabinet ministers
and a crowd of onlookers holding
welcoming banners now we can say
Thailand is really open for all tourism
they were the first to visit the country
since China reopened its borders after
three years of heavy restrictions
before the pandemic Chinese Travelers
were the largest source of Tourism
Revenue globally spending 255 billion
dollars around the world
the travel analysts say limited flights
travel restrictions and lower demand are
slowing down the return of these big
spending International visitors at least
for now
for nearly three years strict quarantine
requirements have kept millions of
Chinese tourists from traveling abroad
travel into and out of mainland China
dropped by more than 94 to 8.8 million
trips in 2021 from 170 million in 2019.
but in January China's government
removed the restrictions that stifled
the flow of these Travelers who were
particularly important for tourism
hotspots in the U.S Europe and Southeast
Asia take Singapore for example where
visitors from mainland China made up
nearly a fifth of international arrivals
in 2019 and spent around 3.1 billion
dollars businesses in Southeast Asia
have lost an estimated 6 million tourism
jobs since 2019 and have struggled to
find alternative sources of revenue
now even as some countries begin
welcoming back Chinese tourists analysts
say the regional industry won't recover
until 2024 and maybe even longer for the
rest of the world
so why will recovery take so long
firstly flight capacity is limited when
China closed its borders to
international travel in 2020 many
airlines rerouted their fleets to serve
other destinations and now with high
Fuel and operational costs many are not
rushing to resume pre-pandemic routes to
and from China days after China reopened
its borders there were only 16
international flights scheduled to
depart from Beijing Capital
International Airport
and then there's the travel restrictions
some governments are wary about Rising
covert cases coming out of China and
have implemented travel rules in
December Italy traditionally among the
top destinations for Chinese tourists
became the first EU country to introduce
covert testing on arrival for those
coming from China many other countries
have announced similar requirements
prompting China to criticize the
measures
and lastly the demand for traveling
abroad is still low today flights in and
out of Northeast Asia the region that
includes China are still about 60 below
pre-pandemic levels and the Lunar New
Year holidays are expected to see people
mostly travel domestically as they
reunite with family that means demand
for international flights won't pick up
until the second quarter of the Year
according to analysts
the Ripple effects of this delayed
recovery and travel have wide economic
implications
sectors that are connected to tourism
like hospitality and luxury goods have
suffered while Chinese tourists stayed
home shares of some luxury goods
companies such as lvmh have rallied
since China announced the easing of
restrictions and analysts say it's just
one of the industries that have high
hopes for when Chinese Travelers start
spending again
[Music]